on Thursday afternoon New York Mayor
Bill DeBlasio who is a certifiable
treated about the wonders of the left's
favorite new New York icon the bronze
statue of a fearless girl who stands in
defiance of the even more famous statue
on Wall Street bull de Blasio tweeted
quote unlike the charging bull which has
become a symbol of wall street fearless
girl is being a beacon for the fight
against injustice here are a few things
you need to know one the fearless girl
statue is funded by a hedge fund State
Street Global Advisors is behind the
sculpture states for Global Advisors
manages 2.5 trillion dollars in assets
the notion that it funded a statue to
rail against capitalism is idiotic
State Street isn't just representative
of Wall Street it invests in Wall Street
a most general level by putting all
money into funds that track the
performance of the indices as Wall
Street goes so too does fearless girl to
the hedge fund has few female executives
State Street Global Advisors has 28 high
level executives according to the New
York Daily News five are female total
three employment in New York relies
heavily on Wall Street according to the
New York Federal Reserve the financial
services sector represented 35% of all
paid income in the city of New York as
of 2000 and more than 1 in 10 people
employed in New York City were employed
on Wall Street the fearless girl statue
is a bit of stupid virtue signaling by a
firm looking for some good publicity de
Blasio has embraced it because he is a
stupid man but here's what the Blasio
should understand if the boat actually
walks away from New York and the
fearless girl remains the bull is going
to be like all the jobs it'll just be
going on in the distance I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the venture Pierrot show
ah people on the left like de Blasio are
so stupid but it doesn't I'll of that
they're obsessed with the statue that
was put up by a hedge fund because they
think that it's against hedge funds
because stupid we'll talk about that
we'll also talk about I have a theory
I'm developing at the area of what
exactly Trump is doing in foreign policy
which is good because no one really has
a theory as to what is going on there
there are multiple working theories but
we will discuss them I think it's a
theory that will make no one happy and
yet everyone happy just like most of the
things that I said but we'll get to that
in just a second first I want to say
thank you to our advertisers over at
Mack Weldon so if you are in search of
the best underwear the best sweatshirts
the best socks and hoodies and
sweatpants you need to go over to math
Weldon comm M ACK wel do and Mack Weldon
dot-com I'm wearing Mack Weldon
underwear right now and they are
spectacular the underwear are just
terrific and they actually have a line
of silver underwear in shirts that are
anti macro microbial they're natural
antimicrobial so they don't stink as
much as your other clothes which is
exactly what you would like and they are
SuperDuper comfortable they also hold up
really well over time so I've been
wearing you know Mac Weldon underwear
for months at this point not that I
change them nightly guys but I do but
they you know they've gone through the
watch a bunch of times they don't fall
apart they are really really durable
they remain just as comfortable as the
first time I put them on and their
clothes are just first-rate Mac Weldon
com use that promo code Shapiro and get
20% off your first order use the promo
code Shapiro at Mac Weldon comm and they
look good when you go out they look good
when you're in and they are the most
comfortable clothes I own Mac Weldon com
promo code Shapiro get 20% off your
first order again this promo code
Shapiro at math Weldon calm for 20% off
your first order okay well we have a lot
coming up on the show today with the
mailbag that's coming up at the end of
the show which is why you need to
subscribe if you subscribe you can be
part of the mailbag
but don't worry I'll make that pitch
later also we are going to be having we
are going to be having a guest on his
name is Fabio Cuddy he is a Middle East
and northern Africa human rights
advocate and he wants to talk to him
because he thinks that the United States
has an obligation to take in Syrian
refugees if we're going to bomb Assad
and I would like to have that discussion
with him so that I look forward to that
but for you
we begin today with the big news there
are two pieces of big military news big
piece of military news number one is
that Trump is now threatening North
Korea it's unclear what the threat
actually is we move the u.s. naval
carrier and aircraft carrier into the
waters off North Korea and there's been
rumors that we are going to preemptively
hit them if they were going to drop some
sort of nuclear test that seems to me
wild rumor the Trump administration is
basically denied it because that could
precipitate World War three when folks
need to understand about North Korea's
that North Korea has like 20,000 20,000
missiles that are aimed twenty thousand
rockets that are aimed directly at Seoul
in South Korea and there are 10 million
people who live in Seoul so if something
should go wrong in North Korea
then Seoul is immediately under severe
attack and probably hundreds of
thousands of people die so it's very
important that we handle this whole
thing very carefully the other you know
the other sort of response has been that
that the United States is going to take
some sort of retaliatory strike against
the North Koreans if they should test a
nuclear weapon and to demonstrate that
we're not going to stand for this kind
of stuff anymore
you know I think that Kim jong-un has
enough wherewithal to understand that if
he goes to war with us the will wipe him
off the map in five seconds flat and he
would like to preserve his rule
obviously so yeah I think that his kind
of crazy act I'm going to act crazy so
that people leave me alone I don't think
that that's going to work very much
longer because people understand he
wants to stay in power he's not going to
launch a preemptive war on the United
States that finishes him completely that
would be a foolish move in the extreme
and he's foolish and buddies but he's
rational he's foolish but rational the
Chinese are now applying pressure to
North Korea they're saying that they're
going to cut off a lot of their oil
exports to North Korea if North Korea
tries to test a nuclear bomb so good on
the Trump administration for pushing on
that the other piece of big news
yesterday was that the US military in
Afghanistan dropped what is known as the
mother of all bombs first of all I think
that all bombs should have nicknames and
so I think this is awesome
it's called the mother of all bombs
apparently Russia has something they
like to call the father of all bombs so
if you ever got them together they'd
make lots of little bombs and be really
cute but the mother of all bombs is is
apparently a massive massive piece of
ordnance it's like 11 tons of TNT it has
a blast radius of up to a mile and so we
dropped it in the middle of nowhere
Afghanistan
and we killed 36 Isis fighters we took
out a bunch of their tunnel systems we
took out a bunch of their ordnance all
of that is good and here is Donald Trump
praising the use of Moab excellent
pictures okay
thank you over at very very proud of the
people
another really another successful job
we're very very proud of our military
just like we're proud of the folks in
this room we are so proud of our
military and it was another successful
event did you authorize it everybody
knows exactly what happened so and what
I do is I authorized and military we
have the greatest military in the world
and they've done a job as usual so do
you have given them total authorization
and that's what they're doing and
frankly that's why they've been so
successful lately if you look at what's
happened over the last eight weeks and
compare that's what really - what's
happened over the last eight years
you'll see this a tremendous difference
tremendous difference so we have
incredible leaders in the military and
we have incredible military and we are
very proud of them and this was another
very very successful mission so thank
you very busy from when Trump says this
sort of stuff it makes people in the
military feel good it heightens morale
this actually was in the works since the
Obama administration so for months
they've been considering whether to use
the Moab every time I think of Moab I
also think of a moan and Jebusites and
all the other biblical tribes but the
use of the Moab was not something that
the Trump initiated it was something
where the Defense Department came to him
and they said can we use this thing are
you okay with that we'd like to and he
said sure go for it and that's the
difference between Trump and Obama you
know Obama had to agonize for apparently
days and days and days about whether to
go get bin Laden I don't think that's
something that Trump knows over very
much and that's something that is
obviously a very good thing Charles
Krauthammer came out he says look Trump
is returning America to world leadership
obviously he's willing to be aggressive
in his use of military force well we
don't really know what the Trump
doctrine is yet but he's winning isn't
he yes I welcome this I'm not in America
Ferster I thought it was a mistake to
annunciator a doctrine in the inaugural
address
which is we're coming home and scared
that the jeebies out of our allies in
NATO when he talked about it being
obsolete it scared up in the Middle East
the Gulf Arabs were scared to death I
think this is reassuring that we are
returning to the classic American
definition where we include our allies
and your most important we accept world
leadership in a way that had not been
accepted to by Obama and seem to be not
accepted by Trump the candidate well
then this is what's confusing is all
held to a lot of the Trump supporters
and we'll get to that in just a minute
Chris Wallace says that what's very
clear here is the Trump has been
basically humiliating Obama by being as
quick as he is to use military force
when called for and this is a president
in sending a message that he's as
opposed to Barack Obama willing to
project and very comfortable projecting
the use of US force anywhere he feels is
necessary and as again as I say I think
that Donald Trump has shown a
willingness to project American force
what less than a hundred days into
office that we certainly didn't see with
Barack Obama who the Trump
administration openly dismisses as
paralysis through analysis okay so you
know all of this is sort of I think a
little bit a little bit early not just
because you know and not not because I
think from is wrong into what he's doing
I think it's exactly right into what
he's doing but I think people are trying
to graph an ideology onto Trump that he
may not hold and it's a little bit
premature but I'll discuss that in just
a minute first I want to bring on our
special guest today
Fatih okatee is Middle East and northern
Africa human rights advocate
and he's written about what he thinks
the United States ought to do with
regard to Syria and and what the United
States has an obligation to do with
regard to Syrian refugees mr. Olcott II
thanks so much for joining the Ben
Shapiro show so thank you for having me
so you write that we salute the you have
a statement in which you say we salute
those that oppose discriminating against
refugees or discriminating against
individuals because of their race or
religion you think that the Trump
administration is making a huge mistake
by not allowing in refugees you also are
not in favor of Trump strikes in Syria
so let's start with some sprite is Trump
strikes in Syria you say that the
president Trump strikes in Syria
violated
International juanita accountability is
the answer what sort of accountability
are you talking about if nobody's
actually holding Assad to account well
that's exactly has been the problem for
the past six years whether the previous
former American administration was part
of the problem or the solution is not
your division but there was never being
a discussion of conversation and
international conversation about how to
bring asset and everyone else who has
committed atrocities in this particular
conflict so I I mean to me it's just
seem that there is a sort of a missing
missing connection here mr. Trump I mean
during the presidential can be he has
been sort of I mean I'm going to say it
he has been demonizing you know the the
refugee population specifically you know
those relatives coming from countries
with a Muslim majority and the Syrians
are the same it did seem to me that
there is a sort of an inconsistent
policy in terms of you know dealing you
know with sending you know missiles to
hit us up but at the same time not
finding the linkage to this to this
problem the problem is that these
refugees really slept a country that is
has been seeing atrocities and massacres
over the past succeeds and if you denied
that if you fundamentally denied that
you just you don't have an excuse to
send these methods to punish a victor or
or a Putin buton governor so edits yeah
so as I want to I want to ask you a
question about this because this has
been in a contention made by a lot of
people that it's fundamentally
inconsistent as you say for the Trump
administration to fire missiles at an
air base in Syria well also banning
Muslim refugees from Syria into the
United States but isn't it true that I
mean there are 50-plus Muslim countries
all around the world that have the
capacity to take in refugees turkey
obviously has taken in well over a
million Syrian refugees
why do you think that it's the
obligation of Western countries like the
United States or countries in Europe to
take in Syrian refugees who it's I mean
let's let's face it it's impossible to
vet their backgrounds because the
government has no records and we can't
trust the government anyway we don't
know who who's coming in there have been
serious issues with with crime and some
instances of terrorism in Europe due to
refugees not necessarily from Syria but
from places like Libya
you know why does the West have an
obligation to take in everybody or does
the West have an obligation to take in
everybody on earth who is in some sort
of dire human rights trait when an
alternative might be available in terms
of Muslim countries taking in these
thugs but then everybody has a
responsibility to take advantages if
they can and if they will again I mean I
live in a country we're talking about
you know from from Jordan who has also
is a neighboring country to Syria and
has taken you know approximately a
million and a half
Lebanon is another neighborhood country
which has taken more than it actually
takes Turkey has taken so much refugees
in the past few years so in the sense of
the responsibility it's everyone's
responsibility and the problem about the
neighboring countries you just they're
they have been really flooded the
structure cannot sort of absorb extended
you know waves of refugees and it's just
the matter of fact that we cannot
sustain and I think this is the key word
we cannot sustain the neighboring
countries to keep on receiving more
refugees or else or otherwise they will
collapse and we don't want them to
collapse and there comes the disorder of
like the issue of Europe and the United
States and Canada and everyone else you
have a very true point about why other
Muslim countries like Saudi we have not
really mobilized you know these again I
have not provided access to these
refugees in the back but let's just
they are also on the some of these Gulf
countries are on the forefront of
providing substantial financial aid to a
UN agency that is providing aid to these
to these rich languages by the way then
which is by the way another problem that
mr. chunk is is facing in terms of this
inconsistency well now we're talking
about helping the Syrians and
recognizing that America had happened
and something needs to happen but at the
same time he cuts aid to the World Food
Program Agency which basically provides
food but he is not what he's talking
about he talked about increasing it
pretty dramatically for refugee program
specifically Syrian refugee programs in
the area by sponsoring refugee camps in
places like Turkey you know one of the
questions that I have here is that you
say that every country has sort of an
equal obligation to take in refugees in
human rights situations obviously that
has not been true historically obviously
you know but to take a take an easy
example the Palestinian refugee crisis
has been on has been on the hook for 70
years plus and Jordan took in many
Palestinian refugees and then pushed
them out to Lebanon Lebanon pushed out
those Palestinian refugees to Tunis so
the issue of refugees the problem that I
have here with with a lot of the talk
about who should take in refugees is it
assumes that all cultures are equally
malleable and assimilate easily easily
to the cultures that are supposed to
take them in it seems to me that it
should be easier for Jordan to absorb
refugees from Syria than it would be for
France to absorb refugees from Syria
given cultural differences which do make
a difference in terms of how people have
grown up what what form of Islam people
practice because in all forms of Islam
are equally peaceful you know the idea
that you have to take in a refugee in
order to oppose this lauter of civilians
I don't think the deaths I don't see how
that follows in other words why would
why is it bad that Trump is trying to
bomb Assad and stop aside from
committing gas attacks if Trump doesn't
take in Syrian refugees it doesn't seem
like there's a connection between the
two you may think that he's wrong not to
take in Syrian refugees but why is it
now bad for him to bomb the airfield
from which Assad is launching gas
attacks well let's put it this way then
the issue about sort of you know the
global response
need to sort of protect those who flee
atrocities I you know I just I don't
think it's just a moral issue and I I'm
not quite sure that it is sort of you
know the issue about cultural
differences can substantiate the issue
of of the needs of protection we have
also to recognize that in some what you
just said or refer to as culture there
in order to be an adequate sort of
structure to provide production to these
to those people who are fleeing
massacres and atrocities and I sort of
think the neighboring countries have
sort of grown to a point where they can
no longer provide such a such protection
so I think that the main difference here
is that some countries some cultures as
you referred have more sort of advanced
more of substantiating structures that a
bit you know that makes them capable of
providing such protection the other
point I think is that when we talk about
you know mr. trans administration that
are sending these methods to punish us
and if the action do not punish gossip I
think what we need from mr. Trump is a
sort of a clear policy on accountability
and in what we refer to a being
accountability is just to find sort of a
venue an international venue to
prosecute those who are responsible for
crime there could stop you know our
Joseph is America Russia would never
stand for that obviously and that's one
of the problems here in the
international community's the unilateral
action becomes necessary when there are
international actors who won't cooperate
in all of this but thank you for your
time I really do appreciate the
perspective that this part of y'all Cudi
he's a Middle East and northern Africa
human rights advocate thank you so much
appreciate all the way from Jordan thank
you thank you okay so back to what's
going on with regard to the the Trump
administration policy here so obviously
Trump has been very militaristic his use
of mob his use of the his militarism
with regard to Assad so what exactly is
going on here so I have a working theory
that I'm going to tell you about but
first I say thank you to our sponsors
over at stamps.com so if
you are in need of postage and you are
if you run a business
then stamps comm is the best way to do
it you go to stamps comm you can print
right out on your desk all the postage
that you need you can stick it on an
envelope you can put it on a sticker and
then take that sticker and stick it on
an envelope you can you can have a
digital scale they'll ship you a free
digital scale right now when you go over
to stamps comm and click on the
microphone at the top of the page and
type in that promo code Shapiro stamps
comm promo code Shapiro you don't have
to go to the post-office and stand in
line ever again if you go to stamps comm
right now if you go there then you get a
four week trial including free postage
and the digital scale if you go to
stamps comm go to that upper corner
click on the microphone and type in
Shapiro and you get that deal again you
know one of the most annoying things in
life is having to stand in line at the
post office and wait for those stamps so
you don't have to do that anymore plus
again that digital scale means you can
weigh everything right there on your
desk okay so here is my theory about
what's going on with the Trump
administration foreign policy there are
two theories that are been put out there
theory number one is the theory that
President Trump is basically being
co-opted by all of the evil neo cons in
the administration that it's basically
Reince Priebus and it's it's it's
general mattis and it's all these
members of the administration who are
neo cons nikki Haley all of the
interventionist the globalist who
are taking advantage of President Trump
and President Trump is basically being
led astray by these people this has been
the line that's been taken by people
like Ann Coulter who is never willing to
take Trump on directly but instead will
sort of blame his action on the people
who surround him so theory number one is
that Trump is being co-opted by the
establishment here's Ann Coulter
basically expressing that theory and for
that reason region of the world
Assad is one of the the better leaders
they're probably only one or two that
are better than he he's not even like a
Saddam Hussein murderous thug he helped
us after 9/11 giving us intelligence
it's a very strange thing we've done
here and I feel like it is such a
departure from what Trump said on the
campaign trail and in 2013 on his
Twitter feed right okay and and so she's
sort of saying it's a departure and
your stone who's sort of this conspiracy
minded guy who worked closely with Trump
he says that that Trump is being
co-opted and Steve Bannon is basically
being attacked by all the neocon
globalist van tonight well I'm
kind of your friend of his and you
I think share a little bit more of his
ideology than perhaps that would be fair
Kushner or mr. Priebus if he's getting
elbowed out what does that tell you
well it tells me a couple things first
of all I think Steve made an error by
not spending any of his political
capital to bring other crumb bites and
non globalists into the White House
Circle so now he didn't do a good job
staff in the White House he's alone
right Reince Priebus and Jared Kushner
did yes
and so therefore now he's alone and he's
surrounded
I think unfairly perhaps he takes the
rap for the fiasco surrounding health
care maybe rights should be wearing a
bit more of that the travel ban is also
probably counting against him although I
would argue that in Donald Trump's case
he only suffers politically not when
he's defeated but when he stops trying
okay so again the idea is that Bannon
has been surrounded by this cabal and
they're taking advantage of Trump so
that's Theory number one is the Trump is
being co-opted by this evil cabal it's
not Trump's fault he's just being
co-opted by this evil cabal theory
number two is is a little bit different
theory number two is that Donald Trump
basically just reacts that something
happens and Donald Trump react and there
is no plan and he's just acting how
Donald Trump has always acted which is
he reacts to the news that's on TV and
there's a fair bit of evidence to
support this basic case here's Sean
Spicer saying that basically Eric Trump
and Ivanka Trump push Trump into
reacting to the gas attack in Syria
there is no question that Ivanka and
others weighed in to him as you know it
was asked earlier Hallie Astin that when
he himself saw images he was very very
moved and I think Ivanka and others
frankly I don't think that there's many
humans that came into contact with the
president during that window of time
that said did you see those images on
television so I don't
you know I think there was a widespread
acknowledgement that the images and the
actions that have been taken were
horrific and required action okay so you
know the story is that apparently a
bounce I came to Trump and she said it's
really bad what's happening in Syria
said great its Bobbitt that's basically
how the story went and then here is
Trump describing the moment that he
chose to make the decision to fire the
missiles at Assad in Syria I was sitting
at the table we had finished dinner
we're now having dessert and we had the
most beautiful piece of chocolate cake
that you've ever seen and President Xi
was enjoying it and I was given the
message from the generals that the ships
are locked and loaded what do you do and
we made a determination to do so the
missiles were on the way does that seem
like someone with a worldview I was
sitting there eating a piece of the most
beautiful chocolate cake let me tell you
this chocolate cake was just big-league
big-league chocolate cake and the
president kind of loved it loved l.u be
e.y loved I mean it does this sound like
somebody with a plan so I guess the the
second theory here is that Trump to sort
of lashes out here is my theory my
theory is that both are true
basically Trump reacts to a certain
thing and then Trump responds to the
applause based on that reaction so if
you react so it followed that follow the
course of his campaign basically he
leads off his campaign by talking about
Mexican immigrants coming across the
border and committing crimes and a
certain cadre of people cheer and love
it and they think it's just great how at
least Trump is saying this sort of thing
and Trump responds to them and he
panders to their applause because Trump
is motivated by one thing and one thing
mostly and that is love of Trump if you
love Trump you are great right Trump has
said this about in interviews about
Vladimir Putin who likes me that means
he's okay right did this has been from
sort of theory his working theory of the
world for seventy years if you like
Trump that makes you good if you don't
like Trump that makes you bad so
something happens like a gas attack in
Syria Trump responds because Ivanka says
it's bad he says okay let's fire some
missiles and then who's going to respond
positively to that well it's not going
to be all of the people who Bay
Tim's not going to be the alt-right
group it's not going to be the
isolationists not can you tap you can
it's going to be all of the you know
more interventionist hawkish people on
foreign policy those people will cheer
him and so then he falls into their
thrall because he starts pandering to
their applause now Ivanka and Jared are
leading the crew instead of Bannon so
Bannon was leading the crew when
everybody was applauding him for his
trillion-dollar infrastructure package
and for his talk about how he was going
to put up tariffs that was bandhans
doing and so Bannon was the guy
applauding the loudest without wind
Trump was friends with him now Benin
doesn't like what he just did in terms
of reaction when so now he's fallen
under the sway of Ivanka and Erick at
least up to the point where he does
something about then Jared and Jared
don't like and then he turns on them in
favor of another ideology now what does
that mean for the future of the Trump
administration we'll talk about that in
just a second but for that you have to
go to daily wire comm and become a
subscriber $8 a month makes you a
subscriber over at daily wire comm we do
have a live mailbag today we are doing a
special Friday mailbag here on ben
shapiro show you can be part of it you
can send your questions in live right
now if you subscribe move really fast go
there and if you get an annual
subscription you get a free copy of the
Arroyo fictional border film set
obviously on the southern border by
jeremy boring all about the it's it's
about a rancher who's trying to defend
his land against the encroachment of
drug cartels into his land really really
good action flick and you can go check
it out over at Daley wire.com getting
the annual subscription plus make sure
you go over to iTunes or SoundCloud and
subscribe and then leave us a review we
always appreciate it we are the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
you